[«ДахаБраха» виступають на сцені]
Дякуємо вам!
Це любов!
[глядачі аплодують]
Ви зробили це свято, дякуємо вам!
Фух...
А де Семен?
У метро...
Вони всі у переході каву купують.
— Каву?
—  Ага...
Добрий день!
Добрий день усім!
Мене сьогодні жіночка старенька запитує:
«А в якому ви театрі працюєте?»
Я кажу : «В ДАХу, ДАХ».
А вона каже: «А де це?»
«Це на Либідській», — кажу я.
А вона каже: «Це що, в Ocean Plaza?»
«Та ні, — кажу я. — Це там житловий будинок є,
на першому поверсі».
А вона: «Що ж це за театр такий, що «ДАХ»
називається. Він має бути на даху Ocean Plaza!»
І я: «Ааа, ну зрозуміло...»
[Сміється]
На даху Ocean Plaza...
[російською] Ще й феномен, що якщо ви були б в Європі...
[російською] У центрі міста ніколи немає таких
великих торгівельних центрів.
[російською] В основному вони знаходяться на околиці міста.
[російською] А в нас тут ось так...
[російською] І ось — мікроДАХ, тобто пропорція площі,
[російською] це і є те, що в нашій країні важливо.
[російською] І оце відчуття, яке тут...
[російською] Добрий день! Вибачте, ми в затор потрапили...
[російською] В який затор?
[російською] Ось тут?
— [російською] Ми з цирку їхали...
— [російською] З цирку їхали.
До ДАХу не можна відноситися,
як просто до театру.
Тут ти..
Тут тобі ніхто не платить гроші за те,
що ти ходиш на роботу.
Ти це робиш, тому що тобі це потрібно.
І Влад так робить, що воно живе...
Воно повинно, як діти...
Він до цього відноситься, як до дітей.
Це старші, це внуки, це правнуки...
Тут така його природа дивна...
Це таке дивне місце, в якому ти відчуваєш Бога.
Будучи в ДАСі, ти, як на даху світу,
можеш доторкнутися до його долонь.
Був відкритий набір, і так
я познайомився з Владом.
Він сказав: «Хочеш? Побігли!»
І я побіг, як міг.
Я брався за все, що можливо було.
Я брався за менеджмент...
Я був монтажником сцени,
я вивчав світло так само...
Я пройшов різні етапи: від глядача,
волонтера, координатора програм,
учасника, стейдж-менеджера, промоція, сайти...
І зрештою 2016 року я став куратором
театральної програми
і останні три роки я масштабно цим займаюся.
[російською] В цьому приміщення був «ТЮГ» і,
звісно, присмак радянського театру тут  був.
[російською] Тому фактично тут треба було все..
[російською] І ми з дружиною, мамою і татом
тут все ремонтували.
[російською] Не було в мене нічого...
[російською] І до того ж, я брав в борг, щоб...
[російською] Якого біса я це робив?
Треба задати собі це питання, я не розумію...
[російською] Це було безумство.
[російською] Але що зроблено, те й маємо...
[російською] Як каже КЛІМ, ми помираємо через те,
що шкодуємо про незроблені справи.
[російською] Тому є завжди варіант зробити,
придумати або не придумати,
[російською] знайти 500 мільйонів виправдань,
чому це неможливо зробити.
[російською] Ну, це завжди:
«Чому? А тому що! Це — неможливо».
[російською] З самого початку виник образ ДАХу
[російською] як равлика, що повзе
по схилах Фудзі до самих вершин.
[російською] Насправді, як назвеш, так воно і виходить.
[російською] Ось 25 років пройшло, і я розумію,
[російською] що ДАХ своєю неспішною,
неметушливою і чесною позицією,
[російською] своїм не швидким розмірковуванням хай і
не завершив рух, але йде у правильному напрямі.
Глядач заходить...
Ми відкриваємо двері...
Проходить...
Тут зазвичай в нас вісить різна інформація.
Тут в нас офіс.
Тут стоїть людина, яка перевіряє квиточки, списки.
Далі глядач може піти в гардероб,
вбиральню, залишити речі.
До речі, в ДАХу колись була кльова традиція:
не можна було заходити в театр у взутті,
в якому ходиш по вулиці.
Тобто ти мусив з собою приносити змінне взуття.
Були навіть періоди, коли глядач зберігав
тут змінне взуття, як у себе вдома.
А потім ми запрошуємо в хол.
Дуже важливо зрозуміти, що оскільки простір невеликий,
насправді саме тут народилися всі проєкти.
Тут народилася «Даха Браха», тут
народилися Dakh Daughters...
Тут народилися «ЦеШо», «Nova Opera»,
фестиваль «ГогольFest»...
І прямо на ваших очах народжується
новий проєкт...
Проєкт, заснований на творчості Василя Стуса.
І це зовсім свіжа історія, наші актори досліджують.
І незабаром буде прем'єра цього проєкту.
[співають]
Це нова генерація акторів,
яка зараз працює в ДАСі.
Я це називаю «Сила пробуджується»,
як у «Зоряних війнах».
[репетирують]
[російською] Ну наче красивий низький баритон...
Все ніби добре...
[російською] Але тобі цей текст не чеше.
[російською] У тебе особисто є віра? У тебе, у Влада?
— [російською] Зараз?
— [російською] Так.
—  [російською] Ні...
[російською] Насправді, чесно, я не знаю, що таке віра.
[російською] Ну ось і питання, бо ти говориш
і не розумієш, про що.
[російською] Чи являється для тебе це важливим?
[російською] Чи ні? Якщо ні, то це ніяк не можна...
[російською] Безумовно, являється.
[російською] Ну воно для тебе являється,
якщо відчуваєш кризу віри
[російською] і ти не розумієш, що це, але розумієш,
що без нього ніяк...
[російською] Твоє життя не буде повноцінним.
[російською] Ти не розумієш насправді, хто ти.
[російською] Актор чи хто ти?
[російською] Я — актор.
[російською] Ні.
[російською] Владушка, ні, не актор.
[російською] Актор — в якого болить душа.
[російською] Ти можеш бути органічним, все прекрасно,
[російською] але якщо твоє серце не стискається,
[російською] якщо в тебе немає беззахисної твоєї історії,
коли ти безпорадний...
[російською] І не боїшся бути безпорадним...
[російською] Беззахисним...
[російською] Це ж історія... Людина —
одна і поговорити йому ні з ким.
[російською] А кому ти віриш?
[російською] Ти, Влад? Я не про Свидригайлова...
Дуже складно розділити
своє життя в ДАХу і  поза ним.
Це і моя родина, і моє місце сили.
І місце мого становлення.
Влад і КЛІМ —  це для мене вчителі,
і досі вони такими є.
Будь-які питання я можу з ними обговорити
і отримати таку думку,
яку навряд чи мені хтось інший
зможе мені сказати.
Бо вони мислять іншими категоріями.
Тобто тобі пощастило і ти тривалий час
знаходишся поруч з геніями.
Якщо ти вмієш в них щось брати
і всмоктувати в себе, мені здається,
що і ти сам стаєш трохи кращим
в певний момент життя.
Я так, прийнамні, сподіваюсь.
Я завжди з Владом сперечалась і казала, що ні,
це неможливо, це ми точно робити не зможемо.
Я завжди казала на все «ні»,
а він на мої аргументи шукав,
чому ми так маємо робити,
шляхи, і ось на цій протидії
ми знаходили варіанти, як реалізувати
якісь його ідеї і проєкти.
В принципі, ми і досі працюємо так.
У Влада є така дивна здатність
з'єднувати те,
що на перший погляд з'єднати неможливо.
Він — та людина, яка творить синергію.
Тобто тих речей, які неможливо, з точки зору...
Наприклад, моєї свідомості, більш такої...
Більш прямолінійної...
Він бачить щось живе таке і каже: «Хай живе таке!»
«От це спориш, маленька квіточка,
але вона божа», — каже Влад.
Я кажу: «Та ні, квітка має бути велика!»
А він: «Ні! Гарна Квітка!»
«Подивимось, підросте...»
«Та! Підросте! Живе ж росте!»
«Невідомо, що виросте, розумієш?»
І оця віра, що з усього божого
виросте боже — є ДАХ.
♪ [співає] ♪
♪ [відбиває рукою ритм] ♪
Знаєте, коли починається,
мені дуже важливі перші слова, перший тон.
Оце ось «сховатися».
♪ Сховатися од долі не судилось... ♪
Щоб він одразу брав...
— Бо зараз в нас воно трошки...
— Випадає.
— Так.
— Зникає воно, випадає.
Спочатку я не дуже розумію,
куди це буде йти.
А ця річ повинна бути чиста.
[російською] На жаль, в Україні втрачена традиція вчителя,
як носія не тільки формальних знань,
[російською] наприклад, чи то театр,
чи то філософія або ще щось...
[російською] А ще світоглядних,
поведінкових і етичних цінностей.
[російською] Хто цьому навчить?
[російською] Хто дасть ці  цінності?
[російською] Як нам між собою розмовляти?
[російською] Як взагалі зрозуміти поняття «бачити іншу людину»
[російською] і не боятися показати себе, бути відкритим?
[російською] Можливо, єдиний інструментарій
для цього — мистецтво, справжнє.
[розмовляють між собою]
[випробовує мікрофон]
[говорить з різною тональністю]
Театр — це місце, де існують певні сенси.
Тексти, які ми вчимо як актори,
вистави, які ми граємо,
для нас це — певне спільне сенсове тіло,
яке ми тримаємо всі разом.
Майже всі вистави не випускаються готовими
у буквальному сенсі,
а швидше з Владом ми готуємося
до цієї зустрічі з глядачами і
вже потім допрацьовуємо дуже багато елементів,
постійно щось змінюючи, додаючи, шукаючи...
Тобто це, скажімо, дуже жива матерія.
Тому дуже важлива ця актуалізація
на рівні акторів:
«Чому я тут? Чому я це граю сьогодні?»
Такі глобальні цінності, які нас об'єднують.
— Добрий день, Влад!
—  Привіт...
Сонце, ліс, вода — а навіщо тобі я?
Що-що?
[російською] Зрозуміло...
[російською] Так, друзі, скажіть,
у вас з'явилися якісь думки після вчорашнього?
— Так, з'явилися.
—  З'явилися...
[російською] Я хочу поговорити про поняття
професіоналізму, яке мене турбує.
[дзвонить телефон]
[сміються]
[російською] Алло! Зараз, секунду.
[російською] Так, у мене репетиція,
я вийду за 15 хвилин і швидко поговоримо.
[російською] Так...
[російською] Якщо я розумію, що я — професіонал
[російською] і я несу певну відповідальність за те,
що я знаходжусь на сцені,
[російською] то, якщо я елементарно
слухатиму людей на сцені,
[російською] я вже по-іншому до них ставитимуся.
[російською] Я вже по-іншому їх сприйматиму,
[російською] бо протягом трьох годин я віддам
всю свою увагу Ігореві.
[російською] І якщо я з ним не спілкуюся
і в житті в нас щось може бути по-іншому,
[російською] я вже по-іншому сприйматиму цю людину тому,
що я його елементарно буду слухати.
[російською] Ось такі думки...
[російською] Вова, у тебе які питання, скажи.
[російською] Та я не знаю...
[російською] Ні, ну почекай...
[російською] Якщо ти вважаєш, що вчора в тебе було все ок,
тоді не ясно, що ж репетирувати сьогодні?
[російською] Завжди є що репетирувати, я не знаю...
[російською] Це такі речі, які я не можу бачити...
[російською] Ні, Вовонька, вчора в тобі
не було ані грама Раскольнікова.
[російською] Якщо ти не доведеш до кінця цю історію,
[російською] якщо я не відчую це відчуття смерті,
яке відбувається,
[російською] і твоє зізнання, і твій крик...
[російською] Не такий крик звичайний,
а про те, що — зачекайте!
[російською] І потім прийшли робітники...
[російською] Навіщо ти це говориш?
[російською] Ну цього вчора не було, так.
[російською] Ну так!
[російською] А потім ти сидів і чухався!
[російською] Ні, я двічі ворухнувся.
[російською] Ні, ти ворушився весь час!
[російською] Володя, ну розумієш, це питання...
[російською] Що означає відповідальність перед іншим?
[російською] Якщо ти робиш маленький рух в той час,
коли інша людина веде монолог,
[російською] ти одразу вбиваєш його монолог.
[російською] Просто вбиваєш!
♪ [співають] ♪
♪ [лунає ритмічна музика] ♪
♪ [лунає швидка ритмічна музика] ♪
Зараз я опікуюся лише менеджментом
гуртів «ДахаБраха» і «Dakh Daughters».
Для закордонних слухачів це є перша сходинка
до відкриття України, часто перше знайомство
або якесь продовження захопленням
не лише «ДахаБрахою», тобто музикою,
а саме українською культурою,
їм цікаво дізнаватися і відкривати щось нове.
А в Україні людям приємно пишатися чимось українським
і «ДахаБраха» дає їм цю можливість.
Це одна з наших мікромісій —
дати українцям можливість пишатися
своєю культурою і своєю музикою.
Люди переходять на українську мову,
коли пишуть про «ДахаБраху»,
тому що для них це здається природнім.
І це дуже приємно,
хоча ми про це ніколи не думали,
коли зрозуміли, що людям це надає людям
таку наснагу і таке натхнення —
бути українцями і пишатися Україною,
це — одне з найдорожчих,
що можна отримати взагалі за свою роботу
і побачити такі результати.
Це такий містичний подив.
Містичне враження, яке вражає
дорослу людину, як дитину.
І оця здатність...
Пошуку тієї природи, тих справжніх
якихось речей, які притаманні цій землі...
Які роблять цю землю унікальною.
«ДахаБраха», в чому ефект? Тому, що це унікальне
і в той же час єдине зі світом.
Там є глибинна енергія, яка творить людину.
Друзі, спочатку!
♪ [звучить композиція «ДахиБрахи»] ♪
[російською] Існує 2 цивілізації: цивілізація споживання
і цивілізація альтруїзму.
[російською] Їхні головні відмінності — критерії успіху.
[російською] Якщо споживання,
то головний критерій — скільки ти коштуєш.
[російською] А альтруїзм — це зовсім інше.
[російською] Тут питання успіху — що ти можеш віддати.
[російською] Тобто даром.
[російською] Ну, гроші — це нижній рівень.
[російською] Любов, увагу, знання, дружбу...
[російською] Ну це не так просто, бо, з одного боку,
щоб щось віддати, треба його мати.
[російською] А по-друге — знайти того, кому це потрібно.
[російською] Ось коли це співпадає — це успіх.
[російською] Коли те, що ти робиш, ти віддаєш і
потім з'являється феномен «віддати-взяти».
[російською] Звідси і народилася назва «ДахиБрахи».
[російською] Вони якимсь чином піймали,
не побоюсь цього слова, божественну енергію.
[російською] Вони стають такими жерцями.
[російською] Цей феномен надлюдського
робить їх шалено красивими.
[глядачі аплодують]
Слава Україні!
Героям Слава!
Ця кімната називається офіс.
Офіс Центру сучасного мистецтва «ДАХ».
Тут прийнято дуже багато важливих рішень
історичних і ще буде прийнято.
Все просто: 4 стіни, підлога, стеля.
Але насправді кожен предмет
тут має певне значення.
Я хочу звернути вашу увагу на цю стіну.
Тому що це прекрасно візуалізує певний генезис,
шлях, пройдений людьми, що працюють тут.
Проєкти, які створені тут.
Ви бачите один із головних проєктів,
можливо, один із найважливіших.
Це фестиваль сучасного...
Це мультидисциплінарний фестиваль
сучасного мистецтва «ГогольFest»,
який увійшов в п'ятірку найактуальніших
фестивалів Європи саме за те,
що цей фестиваль визначає певні тренди
розвитку фестивального руху в європейському контексті.
Цінності, які транслює цей фестиваль,
і його соціально-культурне значення.
Він об'єднує людей і будує культурні мости.
Ми мали п'ять разів змінювати локацію,
проводячи і запускаючи процеси ревіталізації.
Ми провели близько тисячі подій,
половина з яких була зроблена
з закордонними партнерами, митцями.
Тобто це була дуже потужна історія,
яка дала поштовх розвитку дуже багатьом
культурним і соціальним процесам саме у столиці.
Після того ми змінили стратегію
і почали співпрацювати з регіонами.
Перше місто, в якому ми почали створювати
фестиваль нового зразку, був Маріуполь.
[російською] Добрий день! Тут щось зараз буде?
Так, Оld Days.
[російською] Всередині двору?
Ні, всередині, на малій сцені.
[російською] Ммм, зрозуміло.
[російською] Раніше це був чисто київський фестиваль,
тепер він став національним фестивалем.
[російською] Тобто він об'єднує і зшиває країну.
[російською] Все говорять про зшивання країни,
але не дуже розуміють технологію.
[російською] А ми, власне, робимо цю технологію.
[російською] Сюди приїхали декілька тисяч людей, у Маріуполь.
[російською] Чого б вони сюди приїхали?
[російською] Вони приїхали...
[російською] Так само вони приїдуть в Тернопіль, в Ужгород...
[російською] Насправді це був великий експеримент для влади,
бо вони самі не очікували ефекту...
[російською] Вони побачили, наскільки це пробуджує місто,
тому я думаю, що...
[російською] Цей досвід, цей експеримент
виявився дуже успішним.
[російською] Навіть більш успішним, ніж ми могли очікувати.
[російською] Це руйнує твої шори.
[російською] І раптом ти бачиш,
що світ є, небо — є, Бог — є.
[російською] Зірки є, живи і радій.
— [російською] Добрий день!
— [російською] Дякуємо вам дуже!
[російською] Слухайте, насправді світ роблять...
[російською] Я можу тільки трохи підштовхнути,
а світ роблять люди.
[російською] Але цей поштовх був дуже необхідним,
це — як повітря!
[російською] Кожен камінець дихає тепер інакше,
дякуємо вам!
[російською] Чудово, розправляйте крила і літайте!
[російською] Так, злітаємо! Але ви — просто...
Дякуємо!!!
[російською] Немає за що!
[люди аплодують]
[російською] Так.
[сміються]
[російською] Хто тут?
[російською] Дякую, що прийшли! Вас так багато.
[російською] Хотів поговорити, чи потрібно взагалі мистецтво?
[російською] Я скромно вважаю,
що культура і мистецтво
[російською] у його концентрованому вигляді
формує свідомість,
[російською] тобто дає нам можливість сказати, хто ми такі.
[російською] Воно задає питання і
дозволяє будь-якій людині
[російською] зрозуміти, що, в принципі, все можливо.
[російською] Насправді, те,
що відбувається в Маріуполі, мені дає надію.
[російською] Як люди дивляться, як люди розмовляють —
це теж змінилося.
[російською] Це завдяки, в тому числі,
сучасному мистецтву.
[російською] Принаймні хочеться в це вірити.
[російською] Заради чого ми затіяли цю історію,
[російською] і наш головний меседж полягає у тому,
[російською] щоб місто маскимально собі це привласнило.
[глядачі аплодують]
Браво! Браво!
Чудовий концерт!
Ура!
Нарешті ми всі разом!
Юхуу!
А тепер ніхто не моргає і нічого не говорить!
Єєєє!
[аплодують]
Дякую...
[російською] Трошки видихнемо — і до верстата!